-So great to see you.
I am so excited for this.
"The Kids Tonight Show" --
it's happening.
-Yes!
-You guys --
Alright, let's just go.
Olivia, maybe you start it off.
Tell everyone what
"The Kids Tonight Show"
is about.
-So, it's a talk show,
like "The Tonight Show,"
but more kid-ified.
So, it's four hosts --
four kid hosts.
We've got Dylan, Mykal-Michelle,
Me, and Recker.
-That's right.
-And it's, like, really messy.
There's a bunch of games.
And I think you all
would love it.
It's so much fun.
-Yeah. Come on.
How cute are these kids?
Are you joking me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every single one.
-Thank you.
-Alright, Dylan.
-Yeah?
-What was your reaction
when you got the job,
when you first found out that
you're going be the host of
"The Kids Tonight Show"?
-So, I was doing another job
while I heard this.
And I was like -- So, I was in
the dressing room like,
"Oh, my gosh.
I can't believe it.
Like, really?
Produced by
Jimmy Fallon himself?
Like, really?"
And my grandmother be going to
sleep, like, at like 9:00,
and she stays up
just to watch your show.
She stays up to 11:00 p.m.
just to watch your show, man.
-She does?
-Yes.
-Tell her, "Thank you."
See, I love that.
-Shout-out to Grandma.
-Shout-out to Grand--
Shout-out to Grandma.
Mykal-Michelle, how --
Be honest.
What's it like working with me?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, you are okay.
-Oh, stop, stop, stop.
-No, I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
You were awesome.
I mean, Mr. Jimmy,
take no offense to this,
but you're like a big kid.
You're awesome. You get us.
-No, I love to see --
We all loved you,
because you were -- We shot
the show across the hall,
and it just made everyone
so happy to just see you guys.
You're so talented,
every single one of you.
Recker -- Dude, Recker,
you play the drums on this show,
so you're kind of a band leader,
as well as a host.
Did you get any advice
from Questlove?
-I did.
Well, first of all,
he's so tall.
Like, he's so tall.
But --
-Are you?
Yeah, he is fairly tall. Yeah.
-Yeah, I'm kind of tall.
-Yeah, you are tall.
Yeah. Interesting. Yeah.
That's what you
took away from Questlove?
That he's tall?
-No, not that.
But, I mean, yeah,
he's tall, but he, like --
He told me how he got started
busking on the street
with Tariq.
But that's kind of the same way
I started, too, like,
busking on the street
with my band.
And then now, like, we're here.
It's crazy.
[ Applause ]
-Whoo!
-When you guys interviewed the
guests, were you nervous at all?
I mean, because you talked to,
I mean, JoJo Siwa.
You talked to --
You talked to an astronaut.
-Yeah!
-Oh, my gosh.
-That was so awesome.
-Yeah. That's cool, right?
-You know, like, once, we got to
interview a kid who had, like,
over like 200 million followers.
We were like, "What?!"
So, I mean --
-That was a note that has
never been hit ever
on "The Tonight Show,"
by the way.
I can't say
more compliments about you
and how professional
and how awesome
you guys were to work with.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much.
-I loved you so much,
top to bottom.
Everyone loves you. Thank you.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-It's happening, guys.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at
"The Kids Tonight Show."
Take a look.
-My first dog was named Jeff,
and he loved wearing sunglasses
and a baseball hat.
-Okay. Alright.
-Jim-Jim?
-I know who that is.
Don't call me Jim-Jim.
[ All shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yes! Yes!
-Okay, okay. Alright.
Alright.
-Yes!
-[ Laughs ]
-Check out Dylan,
Mykal-Michelle, Olivia, Recker.
"The Kids Tonight Show,"
starting October 14th,
next Thursday, on Peacock.